relocaliser pour limiter la casse
sociale post coronavirus c'est le
nouveau credo des manuels macron face à
la récession à venir dans sa dernière
allocution le chef de l'état annonce un
véritable plaidoyer pour la souveraineté
économique de la france à commencer par
l'industrie pharmaceutique
mais ces paroles vient après des
décennies de désindustrialisation et
d'ouverture à la concurrence api de pays
à bas coûts alors peut-on encore revenir
en arrière aujourd'hui avec quelle
stratégie
jacques sapir on voit ça tout de suite
avec vous bonsoir jacques bonsoir
stéphanie alors jacques à vous avez dû
être plutôt satisfait en écoutant le
président ce que vous deviendriez même
néo macro nist alors oui c'est vrai
emmanuel macron a soutenu des idées que
je défends pour ma part depuis
maintenant de nombreuses années il a
défendu en particulier l'idée de
l'indépendance nationale de la
souveraineté économique etc ce sont des
excellents de choses seulement il faut
quand même rappeler que emmanuel macron
quand il a succédé à arnaud montebourg
au ministère du redressement productif
et bien la première chose qu'il ait
faite a été de vendre alstom aux états
unis quand il est devenu président il a
signé toute une série d'accords de libre
échange
bref on voit bien que au delà des mots
il faudrait déjà qu'il faudrait surtout
qu emmanuel macron s'il veut nous
convaincre maintenant définissent très
exactement les moyens qu'il veut engager
pour restaurer cette indépendance et
cette souveraineté économique
à la question des moyens c'est très
important justement quels sont ils ces
moyens jacques alors ses fans il faut
d'abord rappeler que ce qu'on appelle
l'indépendance stratégique ce qu'on
appelle la souveraineté économique
c'est tout d'abord faire en sorte que
des entreprises en particulier dans les
secteurs stratégiques ne partent pas à
l'étranger ou ne passent pas non plus
sous le contrôle de l'étranger alors ce
qui pose un problème c'est que dans le
cadre de la mondialisation dans le cadre
du libre échange
en réalité ce ne sont pas les produits
qui sont en concurrence c'est en réalité
si vous voulez les modèles sociaux est
en fait si on veut pouvoir lutter à
armes égales avec des pays dont les
coûts sont bas mais dont la productivité
n'est pas si parce que ça comme par
exemple la chine l'inde ou voir le
vietnam
eh bien il faudrait que l'on baisse nos
salaires au même niveau
on voit bien le problème alors ensuite
il ya un autre problème c'est celui des
produits de l'avenir et sur ses produits
de l'avenir il faut les identifier il
faut aussi attirer sur notre territoire
les entreprises qui pourraient avoir les
capacités de les produire
bref il faut et qu'on le veuille ou non
une forme de planification donc jacques
à la base il y aurait un problème de
coût du travail
oui parfaitement ces faits alors il faut
toujours rappeler une chose c'est que le
coût du travail
ces deux facteurs tout d'abord
évidemment ces deux niveaux des salaires
mais c'est aussi le niveau des
prestations sociales qui sont payés que
ce soit par les salariés ou par les
entreprises
justement pour financer un modèle social
et c'est pour ça que le libre-échange
pose un problème réel extrêmement
important sur le modèle social seulement
il ya il faut rappeler une chose quand
vous avez votre souveraineté monétaire
si par exemple tu fais de progression de
votre modèle social vos coûts sont en
train de monter
évidemment votre balance commerciale se
détériore et donc naturellement votre
monnaie se déprécie ainsi c'est ce qui
s'est passé si vous voulez avec la suède
qui a laissé sa monnaie se déprécie au
début des années 2000 d'environ 20% et
qui grâce à cela a pu maintenir très
largement en l'état son modèle social
seulement nous ne pouvons plus le faire
depuis tilly à l'euro hélas si vous
voulez il est intéressant de regarder
des calculs qui ont été réalisés par le
fonds monétaire international
enfin le fonds monétaire international a
calculé
quel était l'impact du taux de change
unique de l'euro sur des économies et on
voit très bien que en fait l'allemagne
est largement sous-évalué
économie et une monnaie donc avec l'euro
qui est sous-évaluée alors que d'autres
pays comme la france l'italie l'espagne
voire aussi citer la belgique ont des
monnaies qui sont fortement surévalué de
25 à 45 % et c'est ce qui explique très
largement les succès commerciaux de
l'allemagne et le fait que l'allemagne
arrive à maintenir une industrie alors
que nous comme les italiens comme les
espagnols nous nous des industries à
disons alors jacques le problème
concerne aussi les pays européens en
dehors de l'euro oui tout à fait parce
que si l'euro explique beaucoup de
choses
il est loin de tout expliquer et il faut
toujours rappeler une chose c'est que du
fait du libre échange et bien on a des
écarts en termes de coût du travail
et puis on a aussi les écarts en termes
de productivité sauf que ces écarts en
termes de productivité du fait de la
liberté de circulation des capitaux du
fait que cela permet des investissements
dans des pays qui ont des très bas coût
elles ne sont pas du tout du même niveau
alors prenons simplement l'exemple de la
pologne la pologne a grosso modo un coût
unitaire un coût horaire du travail qui
est à peu près de 30% voire un petit peu
en dessous du coût du travail en france
par contre si on regarde sa productivité
elle est au dessus de 55 % de la
productivité français ce qui lui donne
un avantage compétitif extrêmement
important et on peut reproduire ce
raisonnement sur la république tchèque
sur la slovaquie voire d'autres pays
comme la roumanie et la bulgarie
et donc c'est là où se posent un
problème évident alors ce problème ils
se posent au sein de l'union européenne
mais il se pose aussi avec des pays qui
sont hors union européenne
évidemment comme comme je vous le disais
la chine l'inde ou le vietnam
jacques est ce qu'on peut faire dans ce
cas alors ce problème est aujourd'hui
une telle ampleur que il pose en réalité
la question du libre échange et
globalement aussi du marché unique en
europe
en réalité il n'ya que le
protectionnisme qu'ils puissent
justement corriger ce problème
et sur cette question je rappelle que un
de mes collègues yves perez vient de
publier un livre extrêmement intéressant
il ya de cela quelques semaines voire
quelques mois le livre est sorti au
début de cette année
et qu'est ce qu'ils montrent rien ils
montrent que le protectionnisme peut
être justement un instrument pour à la
fois maintenir des industries des
réticences voire aider au développement
de nouvelles de l'industrie
alors ceci dit il ya un dilemme c'est
que soit nous choisissons d'avoir des
produits qui coûte le moins cher
possible
mais à ce moment là nous acceptons une
désindustrialisation et une destruction
de l'emploi et qui dit destructions
d'emplois dit aussi destruction des
revenus soit nous défendons nos produits
nous défendons l'emploi
nous défendons le revenu mais ça veut
dire aussi qu'il faudra à ce moment-là
payer plus cher les produits
alors on n'y at il pas également jacques
le risque de rétorsion commerciale par
ces pays oui tout à fait ce risque
existe mais peut-être modéré à travers
deux idées de mécanique alors le premier
mécanisme consiste à dire au pays voilà
on va mettre des droits de douane qui
vont compenser l'écart entre votre coût
du salaire et votre niveau de
productivité autrement dit admettons
qu'on comprenne le cas d'un pays qui
aurait un coût du salaire à 30% du
salaire français et une productivité à
50% des eaux mettrait 20 % de manière en
fait à ramener à une égalité entre le
coût salarial et la productivité
autrement dit à établir les bases d'une
concurrence juste vous savez c'est en
réalité cela que défend coup que devrait
défendre l'union européenne avec sa
fameuse idée de concurrence juste et non
faussée donc ça c'est une première chose
la deuxième idée que l'on peut avoir
c'est de dire un certain nombre de pays
essentiellement aux pays qui sont au
sein de l'union européenne s'ils
voulaient si on décide d'introduire des
droits de douane dans le marché by il
consisterait à leur dire écoutez on va
vous
redonner l'argent que l'on a prélevé par
ses droits de douane mais à la condition
que dans un délai raisonnable et là il
faut qu'on s'entende évidemment sur le
délai faire sur 20 ans le faire sur
peut-être six sept ans que dans un délai
raisonnable vous fassiez converger votre
niveau de courir votre niveau de salaire
et votre niveau donc de modèle social
avec votre niveau de productivité alors
jacquin vous avez parlé jusqu'à
maintenant uniquement du taux de change
et des droits de douane mais
l'investissement ne peut-il pas aussi
intervenir dans ce processus
oui tout à fait tout à fait raison c'est
fini en réalité il y a trois piliers
dans cette idée de reconstruction d'une
industrie d'indépendance industrielle de
souveraineté économique c'est le taux de
change ce sont les droits de douane mais
il ya aussi bien entendu l'indécision et
ça c'est une chose extrêmement
importante
alors oui il va falloir que l'on
investisse massivement dans la recherche
et il faut bien dire que le cic eux si
on retrouve notre souveraineté monétaire
si on emploie des formes de
protectionnisme et dit le cicr ne sera
plus nécessaire quand le séisme très
cher à l'état et en réalité on pourrait
utiliser une partie de cet argent
il représente un peu plus de 1% du pib
soit un peu à peu près 23 milliards
d'euros par an on pourrait utiliser une
bonne partie de cet argent
justement à financer la recherche
qu'elles soient publiques ou qu'elles
soient privées deuxième chose évidemment
c il va falloir pour les productions
innovantes pour aider les productions
innovantes faire ce qu'on appelle des
préachats autrement dit garantir un
marché aux producteurs justement de ces
produits innovants afin de les aider à
se développer à les aider à faire des
processus de production qui deviennent
progressivement de plus en plus
compétitif sur le marché mondial
et puis le
le troisième secteur dans lequel il faut
développer l'investissement c'est tout
ce qui concerne l'attractivité des
territoires si vous voulez ce sont les
infrastructures de transport mais aussi
les infrastructures de santé les
infrastructures de logement
bref il faut absolument développer tout
ce qui peut contribuer je dirais à la
compétitivité des territoires et pour
cela ils font sombrer en avoir
conscience
il faudra une forme aussi de
planification par exemple ça pourrait
être l'occasion de recréer la délégation
générale aux plans qui existait dans les
années 40 et jusqu'à la fin des années
90 mais peut-on faire tout ce qu'ils ont
une base jacques purement française non
non c'est très clair à stéphanie et il
va falloir de ce point de vue là que
l'état prenne l'initiative de provoquer
des coopérations ou d'inciter à des
coopérations de soutenir des entreprises
qui voudraient s'engager dans des
coopérations internationales et je vais
vous donner un exemple dans le domaine
de la pharmacie
emmanuel macron annoncé et c'est une
excellente chose que la france avait
décidé avec quatre autres pays de faire
un fonds commun pour pouvoir acheter des
vaccins qu une fois qu'ils seront
produits mais il faut bien comprendre ce
n'est pas du tout une initiative de
lieux ce dont il est question là c'est
de la simple coopération inter
gouvernementale
donc c'est cela qu'il faut faire c'est
d'ailleurs cela qui avait fonctionné
avec airbus airbus n'est pas un
programme lié à l'union européenne de
même que a rien à rien n'est pas un
programme non plus lié à l'union
européenne se sont au départ des
coopérations internationales alors le
problème aussi c'est que il ne faudrait
pas se limiter dans cette coopération
internationale
au pays de l'union européenne il
faudrait faire des coopérations
internationales avec d'autres pays la
suisse en particulier qui est un pays
extrêmement dynamique dans les produits
innovants
on peut penser à singapour on peut
penser à l'inde
et on peut penser bien entendu à la
russie 1 conclusion jacques les mesures
que vous proposez ou qui vous semble
souhaitable une petite différence les
avez vous retrouvé dans la location
emmanuel macron t c'est fanny vous dire
une chose
macron n'est pas arnaud montebourg
si vous êtes son projet tel qu'il
l'avait présenté en 2010 s était grosso
modo de faire pour la france une
économie qui aurait associé à un
mouvement des start up dans l'économie
numérique
avec le développement de la finance à
travers la crise du coc vie de 19
je pense qu'il a compris que ce modèle
ne correspondait pas un pays de 67
millions d'habitants si on était trois
ou quatre millions d'habitants
ça aurait peut-être fonctionner mais sur
une population de 67 millions
d'habitants ça ne peut pas fonctionner
et il a donc compris qu'il devait avoir
un vrai modèle de réindustrialisation et
de développement de l'indépendance
économique
le problème c'est que tant qu'on ne
prendra pas le taureau par les cornes et
tant qu'il ne prendra pas le taureau par
les cornes sur les questions de coût du
travail tant qu'il ne posera pas la
question de la souveraineté monétaire
quand tu ne posera pas la question d'un
protectionnisme voire d'un
protectionnisme altruistes comme je lé
défendu eh bien ça ne pourra pas
fonctionner prenons le cas par exemple
des subventions qui sont donnés
aujourd'hui si vous voulez vous équiper
avec des panneaux solaires
c'est une très bonne idée ça fait
progresser évidemment ce qu'on appelle
l'économie verte
sauf que ces panneaux solaires on en
produit pratiquement plus en france on
en produit pratiquement plus en
allemagne
et si on veut en acheter il faut aller
les acheter en chine
on voit bien là tout le problème qui se
pose et ça a été une erreur dramatique
de l'ex est justement la concurrence
détruire l'industrie des panneaux
solaires en france et en allemagne
donc si vous voulez le discours d'
emmanuel macron
pour avoir un minimum de crédibilité et
je dirais même plus il ne pourra être
audible que quand il abordera
effectivement cette question du taux de
change
et cette question du protectionnisme
merci jacques pour toute cette analyse
qui nous a donné à réfléchir merci à
vous et à bientôt sur rt france